aviateur ici votre commande ambre
aujourd'hui première leçon de combat
aérien
exercices de combats rapprochés cas non
seulement pas de mission
nous impose un plancher minimum de 5000
pieds c'est une équipe vous devez me
descendre sinon sinon quoi monsieur
sinon je riposte
lionel leçon à lui donner à s'en charger
monsieur ici on fait un truc à quoi tu
penses le 3 mai qui se fait descendre un
gage disons 200 points
de chance ça fait beaucoup vous parliez
d'un exercice pour savoir ce qu'on veut
monsieur hockey marché conclu phison on
sait m
sans toi tu vaux rien devant sur le
radar il est peut-être quelques pas
derrière
mais dont
doucement avec essaie de bâtir et de
[Musique]
une approche très dangereux
et bakir et autant meslier château
jarrier le score
toi toi
tel match
rockstar île où j'aurai mes gars ça va
lui coûter cher parce que c'est
l'automne
n'est ce pas de chanter
j'étais trop bas on tuerait le prochain
maire
agile
[Applaudissements]
mais ça devrait nous là sauf que non et
là vous en savez un peu plus sur
eurostar
tiens l'internât qui s'envolent baron
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous offrir de prendre ce fait bien or
des 100aines phoenix s'ils ont passé
deux mois tout le monde que bob ça veut
dire un truc marrant autre que robert
quoi relèvent pas bob tu sais pourquoi
on surnomme portman à temps j'ai trouvé
mes yeux
m
unique par des chambres et bien fat ou
un phénix
j'aimerais qu'à droite
pour nous c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle
plantes man et jenny toujours par te
planter
donc on verrouille et une stratégie que
j'avais pas vu depuis longtemps
tu trouves pas ça trop viril moi non
mais pour toi oui
oui l'afrique je sais pas
des caches allemagne
jusqu'à mon jardin
tellement facile
c'est leur relation a dû sécher
j'aime chercher
à l'électro saganash à une même approche
non je reconnais
tmx je dors plus je leur droit pourquoi
de nuxe jusqu'à maintenant on se
retrouve dans l'au-delà pinkman
[Musique]
ces régimes
pas question
obama
[Musique]
reid à gaillac topic il
others je pose une question personnelle
ça change quoi 6 du nom qu'est ce qui se
passe avec marc rich j'ai comme
l'impression qui t'énerve un peu cette
rivière de port louis où là j'ai pas
bouger d'ici
tu me vois mieux là à les régler ça vite
fait paulson
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous les deux
nos amis là comment tu vas t'en sortir
si vous abandonnez vous voulez jusqu'où
tu veux dix ans austère on voit aussi
bas jubba sur cet entretien
le passé c'est le passé pour toi ton
pour moi ça faisait rosario
planches et à s'habiller les gars vous
allez passer au travers
[Musique]
un
dj moi c'est que je ne sais quoi complot
allez
com
non
ah ah
supra j allais roster qui va la voir ont
piqué et août
c'est robin
quentin telle tâche ans
certes il est c'est fini
toujours le même coaster
[Musique]
au tournoi rondo pour les pauvres
c'est bon
dans le mois à bob on a tous ce conte de
retord accélère matière bonsu essayez
donc pas marché
ces dix ans
vous êtes en paix
qu'est ce qu'il fout là je suis à bondy
en face d'interception plausible vous
faites quoi il est fin au dic à gauche
be there franchement c'est le temps de
tirer ses toits ont déroulé on y est
presque tant que sur la cible il est en
train de virer au noir attention on va
cadrer ces germes la terre rouge et
surtout
look et on dit en approche
non
si l'an viii ou ix monde à 0 tdi d'eisai
mon côté hs désolé je peux pas
verrouillé son jeu l'aja levage
ont même raté
éoliennes
est mort ajouté c'est raté coyote est la
place
coyote du bon soir
coyote bon
goût yacht elle a plein et a perdu
connaissance
mayotte
qui va se passer je vais chercher
d'allergan s'accroche à cos v3
accueillante
les coyotes
tél
sa voix
ok ok seillant pour aujourd'hui
c'était tout juste
ouais quoi comme il vient
collision arrière
les vautours 'conserver' je grave
j'aurais dû lait je tiens mon compteur
gauche extincteur
dur dont un chef qui tourne encore y'en
a marre
villebois et le north delpierre
pardon
elle ouvre l
cet endroit
jalix éjection réduction certain temps
de panne hydraulique
grâce à ce concours et les affaires
éjection mais je suis collectionneur